at this point the execution context
looks a lot like a collection of
key-value pairs sort of like an object
now noticing that similarity it would be
tempting to think that in memory scopes
and in memory objects are somehow
actually the same thing this is a
deceptive similarity since the two are
kept so completely separate by the
interpreter and there are so many limits
on your access to an execution context
that don't exist for your access to an
object many of the rules that we've
learned about objects will also happen
to be true for execution contexts but
you can never mix and match the two in
your programs despite all of the
similarities they live in completely
different worlds that almost never
interact just as a few examples you will
never be able to store an array full of
contexts even though you can do so with
objects
you can't iterate over the variable
names in an execution context the way
you would over the keys in an object so
even though they are both key valued
data storage constructs you're going to
be interacting with the two in
completely different ways